the girl made her
boyfriend talk about his trauma and cry
from it and then she used it as ammo
does there come a point where you can
talk about something and as soon as you
feel yourself getting emotional it's
like okay we're not going to talk about
this anymore or do you just not talk
about stuff like that with your woman
because
she may use it
i feel like he was just an emotional guy
yeah
i think he's just i feel like he's just
an emotional guy and maybe like
you know maybe he was beetle from the
beginning to get me like
because really and trudy if like if so
if you're telling i get if you're
telling a story of like abuse and that
and maybe it can bring you to tears
i understand but if you understand
female nature and it was what is saying
before and it like
you know understanding what female
nature is what's good for a woman versus
what a woman wants
to understand like she wants to hear the
story in it and whatnot tell her the
story tell her the story there's no need
to cry about it
you're a grown-ass man now so
i
in conjunction with what you're saying
i had a situation where i told a partner
something that was
personal or like sensitive to myself and
it was used against me in an argument
and so i can relate to him how did she
use it against you in an argument i'm
just curious so she used it as
a reason as to why
certain situations were happening within
oh and the relationship so she was yeah
i have heard girls say that where you're
doing this because of that yes exactly
oh my god you've never healed from it so
that's why you haven't like oh my god
because girls will be like oh he's doing
this because of his childhood
and the men are like i told you that in
confidence and now you're bringing it up
as ammo
yes
and this and this in itself is what i
mean by
men not needing to be vulnerable to
their woman
and probably going to their their boys
their boys or to seek counsel before
bringing topics that are sensitive
because
and
i didn't even think of it as a malice
thing i just understood that men and
women are different men understand if
there's an argument between two men
there's a line i cannot cross
um
to ensure that world war iii doesn't
break out
women on the other hand
the break that loses every anything goes
is what it is like i think i think it's
i think i think there is a line when
it's women talking to women no
no
because a woman a woman talking to
another woman obviously if you cross
that line with another woman that that
other woman can punch you up
i think that women and women will fight
each other
but when is women talking to men that's
women and the sisterhood
and the sisterhood like i think women
naturally like
are nicer to other women not nicer
because it's like more of like
backhanded stuff you know what i mean
but i do think like
women are worse to men than we are to
women you know it is yet women have a
sharper tongue um than than guys do
so especially when you're opening up to
a i can't lie when you're opening up to
a woman you've got to make sure she's
the right type of woman to open up to
you because if not
no
i just think i just think
you shouldn't
be opening up to a woman
about things that could really do damage
yeah
and like
and don't get me wrong i do
want to be have an open relationship
like communication wise communication
wise with a woman all right um however i
understand that there are certain things
that if a girl goes oh i want you to
open up to me i understand i don't need
to do that that's not a need in our
relationship that's a want
um well and it's interesting because i i
have like now that you say it like that
i can think of so many times i've heard
girls say to me like oh he does this
because of that
and i don't think a lot of times they
mean it in a way that's like malicious
i think they're just trying to diagnose
the problem but we're not we're not
doctors you know i mean like you're not
a therapist why are you doing this
i think a lot of women
do it like oh so-and-so is acting like
this because of xyz
and they don't take accountability for
what
they did in this situation as a whole
they'll say oh
he is acting grumpy or he's acting this
way doesn't talk to me because when he
was in a difficult situation when he was
younger he acted the same way and he
hasn't healed from that and it's just
like no did you say something to like
analyze yourself if you have no problem
in it then maybe it is but if you
pissed him off or put him in a difficult
situation where he didn't want to react
in a way that was going to be negative
then he won't talk to you i want to add
a caveat
it was used
in an argument
not just a case where like you you
brought it up like he's probably doing
this because he's that's not an argument
that's diagnosing a problem that's
stating a possible fact and probably a
probable fact as such but using it as
ammo in an argument
is one thing and that's where there is
like a no wonder you're like that
because like yes like this yeah that's
why
that's what i was going to say like i
think um girls do do um use it in a in a
malice sense because like and again it
doubles back to how emotional women are
when it comes to crossing lines with
guys in um in arguments once a girl's
heated
there's no we double back there's no
barriers there's no lines they will say
whatever they feel at that given moment
to hurt you or to make you feel less
than just because they're angry so if
they're angry you also have to feel
angry and they don't care whatever and
if they have ammo if they have like ammo
and this ammo is personal they they know
it's going to touch a different type of
nerve that's going to make you feel the
type of way and if it does that's
mission accomplished to them
and i think it's also and i think it's
also to do with the fact that they know
that a guy wouldn't necessarily hit them
yeah do you understand like because
as
a guy you can tell a guy something
personal and they still want crosstalk
even if they don't like you they still
won't cross that line and and come with
the verbal stuff and stuff like that
because they know that yo you say that
it's just about the next one
yeah 100 do you understand but um
but that with with a goal it's a
different kind of it's a different kind
of thing because dynamics
you'll give you're giving me as a guy
the same signals that if a guy was
giving me these signals it's a fight
so those same signals are blurring up in
my brain
but you're a woman so i can't really
react the way would react and that's why
that's why women do it they know that
they can get you with their words cut
down your character cut down whatever
but they know that you can't you can't
react you can't
hit me you can't do anything only thing
you can say is something to me but
that's not that's not australia yeah
that's not the
nature of a guy is to attack someone's
character
i think i think women men have a natural
inclination to protect women mm-hmm
i just like i think
[Music]
and it could be someone you know someone
you don't know it's just like innate to
protect the woman that's why there's
that whole there's that saying where you
you want to cross an old lady like you
know you want to make it make sure she
crosses the streets you know probably
hold on old lady's bag so which crosses
the street it's like it's that kind of
protection that they want to do for
women and women abuse it yeah i mean
that's why you see situations like the
amber herd stuff come out i mean because
women know we like women know they can
get away with it
because a lot of times there's no
consequence because honestly i think men
are very forgiving like if you have a
problem with a woman men move on women
will never let the guy stop hearing
about it forever for all of kingdom come
and
so a lot of times like women don't face
consequences for bad behavior
it's true and it's partially the guy's
fault too to be honest because if more
women face consequences and more guys
said we're not going to deal with this
women would have to be better because